this is what you want when charlie
decided to come over here and sign that
15 million contract you knew
you got him for these type of moments
gonna be a good job from dave probably
three innings 45 pitches enough to you
know get his work in but get himself
ready for friday
scorch to center
duval retreats
one out
another chance for duval in center a few
steps back charlie's using the big part
of the ballpark two up two down
[Applause]
curveball good photo took it nothing he
could do about that and noah syndergaard
making his second appearance coming off
tommy john surgery yes he did that was a
start back on the 28th bottom of the
first inning no scores it'll be solaire
swaying in a drive hammer down the line
so lair a missile for a lead off homer i
think he's getting the hang of this lead
off thing jeff yeah he's good you can
take him out
get him ready for milwaukee
wow
this one sliced down the left field line
heading towards the corner that'll one
hop into the corner and over the wall
it's a ground rule double for ozzie
and that is a little bit of history for
izzy albies that is ozzie's 40th double
of the season and that puts him
on quite the list he has become now the
10th player
in major league history with three
seasons of at least 40 doubles 20 homers
and five triples so is riley who's worn
out the mets all year with seven homers
and a shot into left field that is down
for a hit dom smith
loads up here comes his throw it is off
target riley moves towards second and is
going to be safe he got in under the tag
throw was high
this one's gonna be
overturned yeah you see they're gonna
turn it
one two fastball swinging a miss strike
three rosario cut down by trevor
williams
and he chases a slider from williams
before this
infield grounded to shortstop
and handled by lindora stretched by
alonso and they get swanson
and perez hits the curveball toward the
middle that's a base hit just above
the leap of all bees
change up mizika is retired on strikes
who puts it in play slowly to short
dansby has all day
charlie morton wanted to tune up i'd say
he's post season ready
game up one hit in two and two thirds
innings with three strikeouts he'll
finish the season with 216 strikeouts in
185 and two-thirds innings
fastball swung on and missed
and strider down on three pitches third
strikeout for trevor williams here this
afternoon runner aboard for freeman who
flied to left his first time up
line drive to right field that's going
to fall in front of conforto based it
cellaire turns second goes to third he's
in there standing or freeman with a
single to right field and they've got
him at the corners one out for ozzy
albies
on the ground alonzo bobbles he'll step
on the bag and that's all the mets are
gonna get ozzie put it in play a gift
run scores it's three nothing atlanta no
balls two strikes to austin riley
another shot with two strikes and two
outs for riley he's almost automatic
right now folks he's on his way to
second two more rbis for austin the
braves have another two run inning it's
four to nothing next up is adam duvall
over his last 18 at the plate and
there's a looping line drive to right
that will fall
riley turns the bag at third comes in to
score
rbi single to the opposite field for
duvall and it's five to nothing braves
popped him up
freddie and ozzy converge it's going to
be
freddie freeman lendore is retired
so it should be a fun one
conforto to left can of corn for rosario
and that's
out number two
strider ready with his 1-1 pitch
and smith smokes it to center but right
at duvall
and that will retire the side a two out
walk the only damage for new york we
head to the home fourth it's still five
nothing
it puts braves at second and third with
one man out
and an opportunity here for jorge
solaire
and solaire hits it hard down to third
handled by vr the runners hole freeman
with runners at second and third and two
out
hit in the air by freddie deep to center
field
nimmo on the run he has room right in
front of the fence makes the catch for
the third and final out freddie gave it
a ride but not far enough
here's the one-two pitch
ground ball head out towards ozzie and
hit weakly as he's up with it throws
over to first base riley's over there
makes the catch one ball two strikes
base is empty for nimmo
line toward left rosario retreats
he swings the first one tries to dump it
into left but rosario is there and it's
a one two three sixth for luke jackson
five nothing braves leaded
lonzo's massive power 37 home runs
but not this time he hits it right to
ozzie back flip and garcia with a strong
throw that was pretty couple of double
plays turned in by the braves today
ground ball right side there is ozzie
he's got it tossed to riley in time to
get dominic smith
yarb theraza and mazika scheduled here
whacked on the ground two bounces to
first easy play for austin reilly and
he'll take it unassisted for round
number one
fly ball right
that'll be easy for solaire two outs
and it's the hat trick for mazika chris
martin has his first strikeout two
scoreless innings for chris
02
swinging a miss smith with a quick
strike out of deormone one down two to
go nimo coming up
and that's maddening the fans grounded
out to second routine play picked up by
ozzy
flips to riley 2.3 million strong in
atlanta
there's a lot to applaud with this team
and smith brings it
on the ground nice pick
long throw across braves win it
five nothing is your final score
how apropos that the braves 88th win
jeff is a
five-nothing shutout over new york
so the braves end one story
and they're about to open a chapter
in a whole new book the 2021 playoffs
the braves next game will be in
milwaukee start the series against the
milwaukee brewers